I absolutely love my job I always want
it to be the beauty director of you know
the leading women's magazine in the UK
I'm Alessandra Steiner I'm beach
director of Glamour magazine today we're
on set shooting a lipstick story you
think how many more times can we shoot a
red lipstick but there's always a way of
taking an existing theme and making it
fresh there is that kind of really
textured ultra glossy red lip I also
really like the depth of this and I
think kind of a deeper lip maybe will
keep the skin a slightly more max and
there's a difference in texture well I
agree and I think in terms of your a
little bit it depends on what kind of
light you feel is right yeah yeah I
think it's just a nice soft light great
okay let's get on with it I'm so excited
about this
hey Greg are you are you good I'm well
oh wow really looks amazing
I get to do so many different things and
that's what I love I get to write I get
to art directions I get to collaborate
with people that I find incredibly
inspiring you never stop learning today
we've got a very special ask Alex for a
life behind the scenes on the glamour
beauty shoot we're doing a lipstick
shoot my absolute favorite thing is
meeting the readers what lipstick are
you wearing I've actually got my makeup
bag here as I always do I love doing
Facebook live social media has
completely changed the job but at the
same time that's what keeps it exciting
for me what are we thinking for the
first one so I'm thinking to use a bit
of a line and maybe this kind of like
berry color you wear lipstick in your
everyday life I'm going out like having
dreams with my friends I love to put on
like a red lipstick I do make sure it
doesn't go all over the place use a
straw ah that's the model trick using a
straw I want every picture to stand on
its own
it's definitely precision work and it
can take quite a long time I like things
to be effortless not to try hard I think
that's the skill of the photographer
pretty tight to the neck I love that you
started with her straight on because I
think she looks so strong yeah they're
really beautiful I think it's a great
start you're ready to move on
yep definitely next good job
the nicest feeling is when you start
seeing with story unfold that one could
potentially be the opener to things
definitely when everybody is there to
rate something beautiful when everyone's
happy it does make a huge difference I
love it it's pretty ombre not
overpowering I like it I always know I'm
gonna end up with something amazing I
just do I just trust my instinct how
gorgeous is this look gorgeous you never
100% know what it's going to end up with
however you can all see the one that's
the shot it's like when you fall in love
you don't know why and it's the same
with the shoot I'm on a high like I'm in
love at the end of the shoot I'm so
happy you know so it's nice good to fall
in love very often it's true
I'm just trying to convey what's in my
head I guess let's try a ps/2 resistance
fashion doesn't have to be a serious as
I want to try and convey on everything
just have fun with them